uh i guess that you can
see my slides and hear me yes
okay
uh can i start already or shall we wait
one minute
now please go ahead okay
so yeah first uh thanks to organizer for
setting up these
this wonderful workshop and thanks for
letting me speak here
and i'll present his work with uh
igor oliveira and artisan baram or where
we link quantum learning algorithms and
circuit layer bonds
so to start let me describe it what are
boolean circuits so you might know it
but
let me refresh it so this is a
computational model that is described by
a
directly directed cyclic graph where the
leaves of this
dag are the inputs to to your problem so
so you have some input and you want to
decide if it belongs to the language or
not
so so the leaves are the input to their
problem and
the the sink uh like or the root of this
this dog
is who will be the output of uh like a
if this input is in the language or not
and the inner nodes of this log is uh
like a they're called gates and they
compute some functions on this
input of for for each gate you have some
input uh input to it and it computes
some function that is
that it is output okay
and boolean circuits they appear in
different forms so you can choose
what different functions could be in
these inner nodes you can
tell how many bits could be the input to
each gate how many bits could be the
output of each gate
how what's the depth of the circuit and
that's here is the
maximum distance between an input node
and
and the output node or and also the size
and the size here let's say is the
number of uh
of gates in your in your circuit
and once you fix these parameters or at
least asymptotically you can describe
distributed classes uh so for example
with a circuit class c you you can you
can talk about a circuit with a specific
gate set
uh with a bounded depth let's say
constant or
and let's say polynomial size okay
and since in this talk uh one of uh
like one of the most important
parameters is size uh i usually
parameterize this circuit class by by
by putting into in brackets uh what's
the size of the circuits that are
allowed in the circuit class
okay and uh
then we can uh say that a language l can
be solved by
uh circuits of type c if there exists a
family of circuit cn
each of each one of them that belong
belong to this class
such that for every input the output of
the separated input x
is equal to one if and only if x belongs
to the language
okay so this is what i mean by a
language being solved by this family of
circuits
but here there is uh some detail that i
glossed over is how this uh
how this family of circuits uh they
appear so
and the point is here each circuit here
is for for a different input size
so for an input size uh let's say n we
have a specific circuit that computes
uh the output of the function for all
inputs
uh of that fixed input size and then for
n plus one you have
you might have a different circuit that
computes
the output of like if the input belongs
to the language
for for a different input size
and we say that this family of of
circuits is uniform
if there exists an algorithm a
that receives an input to 1 to the n and
then outputs the description of cm
okay so so for uniform circuits
we have an algorithm that connects all
of these uh
circuits in this timeline
and usually we are also interested in uh
uniform feminist circuits that can be
computed with uh with
some specific complexity so for example
we could say that
we want to uniform firmware secrets that
com can be computed let's say in
polynomial time or polynomial space for
example
and this is in contracts contrast with
this non-uniform
non-uniform final circuits where now we
have an arbitrary set
of um
of circuits one of uh one for each input
size
and the point is uh in this case uh this
feminist can be very
um uh how can i say
uh uh verite or genius and and and there
might be no relation between cn
and cn prime for and different often
prime
and it turns out that okay this uh seems
to be a very
subtle like a very slight uh
modification in definition but it brings
a lot of weird computational power to
this model and for those who never
who have never seen it we can
see if we can consider for example the
helping problem where we want to decide
if the answer
machine helps and it turns out that
the halting problem can be solved by
non-uniform
circuits but they cannot be solved by
uniform ones
and uh showing a uniform uh
a non-uniform circuit that solves this
problem is very simple so
you can hard code the i
the circuit to be one if and only if the
ice turing machine helps
so so this circuit by definition works
correctly
and on the other hand we know that the
halting problem is undecidable so there
are no
uniform uh family of circuits that can
solve it
okay and uh one of the biggest open
problems in
circuit complex is trying to understand
to compare the the
the computational power of these two
types of frames of circuits
um and in particular uh
for example we believe that that
okay non-uniformity it adds some weird
power
but it should not i think uh most people
or a lot of people believe
that it does not add too much power so
for example we believe that for uh
np for example it does not have uh
so there is a problem np that does not
have a polynomial size uh
non-uniform family of circuits okay
so but on the other hand
from what we know today it could be
possible that
nx so the exponential version of np that
uh it still consists with our knowledge
that it
it that it could have polynomial size
non-uniform
non-firm non-uniform fan of circuits
okay so there is a huge gap between what
to expect and what we can
actually improve nowadays and just to
show
as an example of how hard is this
problem so in 2006
uh 16 sorry uh ryan williams he proved
that nx
is not in acc where acc are circuits
with constant depth
using uh and or not and mod m gates
polynomial size and uh although this
family
the circuit class is very small and very
shallow uh
showing that non-exponential uh time is
not contained
in this circuit it is a breakthrough and
a very important result in complexity
and just to establish like a at least
informally our result what we show is
that if if we can achieve
non-trivial quantum learning for some
sort classes
then this implies circular bounds so
this is a surprising way that how how
quantum
or how quantum algorithms are more
specifically how contour learning
algorithms
can help us solve a very important
problem in complexity theory
and in order to also are there any
questions up to now
so yeah if you know i'll continue but uh
feel free to stop me
whenever there's something that's soft
here
uh so to continue let me first describe
what our
quantum learning model is so
so in this learning model we fixed a
feminine function c
and i'm using the same calligraphic
letter like the same letter because
in this result or in this talk uh are
the functions that we want to they come
from circuits
and uh we fix a specific function
f that can be solved uh like like the
the does it say there's a truth table
uh or like this function sorry
this is a function that can be computed
by this family of circuits
and what you're interested in using
learning algorithms for for the circuit
class
uh so the idea is that this learning
algorithm has oracle access to this
unknown function so here we use the
standard
quantum query model where on input x and
b this arc outputs
x and b x or f of x
and we want that our learning algorithm
outputs some quantum hypothesis
u that uh and such that
with high probability u is close to f so
what do i mean by
this unitary u being close to f so what
we want is that
uh when d when you run this unitary
on input x and some auxiliary bits uh
uh uh initialized by zero
then the output so of this unitary
uh when you consider the output of this
unitary it should be
uh f of x with high probability
okay so yeah this is it should be 1
minus that from here sorry about that
so so the idea is that when you run this
unitary on input x
the the the first qubit should be f of x
with high probability
and uh what we want is that this happens
with high probability so the probability
over this learning algorithm we want
that it outputs u
that has its property which probability
at least one minus that
okay and notice that these uh in this
model that i
described to you there are two main
changes
[Music]
two main differences from standard
learning algorithms
the first one is that we're we deal with
uh
like we're allowing queries instead of
samples so usual
learning algorithms they're given
samples and here it's a bit stronger so
we allow clear access to this function
and more interestingly it also allows
quantum hypotheses
so usual also usual learning algorithms
the
the the hypothesis are is a classical
circuit but now we allow it to be a
quantum media
but i'd like to have them have a quick
question
um yes so sorry i'm a little i find it a
little confusing so
you i i thought um so is there a sense
in which this is a uniform model of
computing
so that you know what you were saying on
the last slide applies that
you're showing that uh
no okay about this learning algorithm uh
okay let's say that this learning
algorithm is uniform so there is an
algorithm that
computes uh like the the point is the
class the circuit class c
it could be any class like it could be
more general it could be just a class of
functions
and this algorithm a is uh let's say
it's uniform
okay so i'm just describing what's the
learning algorithm for now it's not
about
like uniform or versus known uniform
comes when we were discussing this
circuit class
c
is it clear rush no um
so so i was a little unclear about um
you know you you said about nx versus
acc you know that was comparing a
uniform to non-uniform
class right oh yeah yeah sure yeah so
here
once you talk about learning it wasn't
clear to me how that
the what the analogy is oh no no no okay
so
okay okay the learning the the analogy
will come
when we when i instantiate these uh
these
blocks like when i explain my result our
result with
more details and for now i'm just giving
you some information that allow me to
to give precisely what you mean by this
okay so so i'm just here describing what
a learning model is
and then i think in one or two slides
i'll describe my my
our main result and then if there are
any questions there i can stop again
actually can i ask one more question so
um when the output
is this quantum hypothesis you uh what
form
is you let's say you describe the
unitary i i give a description of
of you as a matrix as a no
polynomial side circuit as a circuit
okay yeah let's say it's a circuit
any other question
so yeah i'd like just to to highlight
that these allowing these stronger
models where we allow uh unitary as an
output
and you where you have query access it's
actually better for us because
our result means that if you find a
learning algorithm then you have circuit
layer bounds
so the easier it is so the stronger the
two model is
it's better because it should be easier
to find a learning algorithm in this
case
okay so so this i just want to point out
that these are actually
helping us in some sense to find
circular bounds hopefully
so now now uh i can describe our result
in a bit more details so what we show is
that
if there exists some parameter gamma
that
that that you can pick whatever you want
such that
the size of polynomial polynomial size
circuits of some circuit class c
can be learned with error epsilon
end time t where epsilon is uh
like that the error that is uh this
algorithm algorithm could do
is half minus uh gamma
and the time that this quantum algorithm
can can run is a gamma
squared times two to the n over n okay
so so if you have such a quantum
algorithm with these parameters
then we have the bqe so then the
uh problems that can be solved in
quantum
exponential time is not included in the
circuit class scene
okay so here okay what we're showing
here is that if
this type of learning algorithms exist
uh you have this uh uniform versus
non-uniform large bound here so we're
showing that this non-uniform circuit
class
does not have this uh uni like we should
show this uh
lower bound to it this uniform lower
bound to it
okay so this is the analogous between
the nx and acc for example if you show
uh a quantum learning algorithm to acc
then it would show that bqe is not in
acc
okay this is the the precise
type of statements that we're looking
for
so umash does it clear up things a bit
yeah i guess um i guess i
you know what's unclear to me is is to
what extent there's something
non-uniform already
in the definition of learning so you
know
nx there was there was a completely
uniform class and a completely
non-uniform class and there's both
complexity classes
that are being compared it's
intermediated through
this notion of learning which already
seems like a non-uniform notion no no
no learning the learning algorithm is
uniform
so so so yeah
so the only thing that's non-uniform is
the secret class c
wow okay okay
so so maybe uh can you can you see that
that's what i was asking during the
definition of that sorry sure so let me
go back so so here we have this
uniform family of circuits or learn
algorithms a yeah and it's given
oracle access to this let's say
non-uniform circuit class c
and what we want is that like this
algorithm that's uniform making queries
to f
output a hypothesis that approximates f1
okay yeah good uh i'll i'll
just think about it offline great yeah
thanks okay
so yeah i'd i'd like to to first
talk about uh two types of learners that
are what you call trivial learners
and the first one is a very simple one
so you have a learning algorithm
that uh can run in exponential time
and has error zero
sorry alex can i ask you one more
question of course can you can you just
say some intuition
here uh uh okay so nicely
you know you have a you say if something
can be learned then it must be very hard
so can you
can you just point me in the right
direction it seems to be turned around
for me
so why is that intuitively uh the right
direction
uh you uh so what you mean
in the right direction why such
statements are not trivial in some sense
no
no no no uh not not but it's not true
but um
you know so normally i would think if
some some class can be learned then it's
it's easy enough to be learned saying
well if it's
if it's learnable then it must be very
hard so okay
can you can you say some intuition about
why that's
why i'm well i don't know this is
showing that no this is showing that the
class is hard right
uh that's right the class is easy
because it does not contain between
oh it doesn't contain oh sorry sorry
that that's very standard okay
sure okay so so this is showing that
this class is not so big as
like okay it should be true for for
simple classes but this is showing that
this is like this proven that's not true
okay sorry sorry alex there's a question
from ronald uh
in the q a he asked if gamma is constant
then why is it written as gamma
squared uh 2 to the n divided by n
oh no gamma could be any parameter that
you want
and i'll okay i'll give two examples and
in the second
example gamma will be exponentially
small
so so the first one okay the first uh
type of trivial learners that that i'm
defining is that the learner that just
learns f by creating all possible inputs
start a truth table and then whenever
you have some input x it can can just
look to the stress table and
output the correct value right this is a
valid learner and it
runs in time two to the n and it has a
error zero
and a second type of trivial learner
that that works
and they are true because they work
actually for every possible function so
every function can be learned with
time uh two to the n and error zero by
by
just uh this um straightforward brute
force search
like lookup table
and the second uh trivial learner that
works for any function is
by doing fully assembling and it takes a
poly time
and it has error uh one or uh one over
two minus
uh two to the minus n over two and
this learner is just by uh applying a
hadamard
uh like uh is just by by uh
sampling one of the fourier coefficients
of f and
it's not hard to see that this gives the
the the
like this approximation like half minus
uh
uh big omega and two to the
minus n over two okay so i don't explain
how it
goes but but uh like it's a simple
analysis that shows that
it's free sampling gives us these uh
this bounds
and if you look to this uh so uh if you
compare these two trivial learners
with the parameters that we have
it turns out that a slight improvement
of any of these trivial learners
give the circuit lower bounds okay
because uh here you can uh
okay the time here in the first learner
will be
2 to the n over n but here in this first
learner we have 2 to the n and
in the second one the error would be
[Music]
sorry
whereas in the second case would have
time that would be
i i guess at the one over n but uh if
you can bootstrap to paulie n
then then then uh then then you already
also have um
the circular bounds so just to summarize
what our result is saying that if you
can have a non-trivial learner so if you
can improve a little bit
on either of these trivial learners then
it already
implies secret larms
and uh oh there's just
okay some footnotes where like
the circuit class it has to be like in
order to our theorem to
hold uh we need the c to be close under
restriction and simulate
by polysized circuits but there these
are very standard assumptions that
that holds for most uh circuit classes
that we know
and if there are no further questions
i'll try to give an idea of how to prove
such a result
oh just before before that um a way of
interpreting a result is that okay on
the one hand
we can be happy and think that now we
have a new approach a quantum approach
to prove these uh long-standing uh
open circular bounds but
on the other hand it also shows that the
proving
quantum learning algorithms is hard
because
if you're able to do that we're also
solving very important open problems
alex there's a another question in q a
by abhinav
regarding the first trivial learner why
is it a learning algorithm in the sense
that
you describe how can you ensure that
there's a uniform algorithm that outputs
the truth table
so you're yeah so you have a learner
right you you
you're learning algorithms just iterate
over all possible
all possible inputs and collect of the
outputs and and and these
with these you can compile a unitary
exponentially large unitary
that that computes the function so this
is a valid learning algorithm by by what
i define here right so
a is just iterating over all x's
collecting the output
collecting f of x and outputting this
this gigantic unitary that that computer
function
there's another question from the q a
ronald asks uh
regarding the second trivial learner
fourier sampling returns in s such that
chi sub s or minus chi sub s has error
at most one half minus omega two to the
minus n over two
but how do you know which one oh so
that's why oh sorry
yeah i forgot to talk about here
delta we want the delta in this learning
algorithm to be a constant
so you can just pick one of them
infirmary at random and then you have
your half here like we're not uh
we're not aiming for something that is
very close to one we just need a
constant here so
picking either of them is fine
like picking one of them in from that
random uh will give us the right uh you
you do the correct choice with what you
have
so let me now give a summary of how how
you achieve a result
so the first thing is showing that a
quantum learning algorithm implies what
we call
quantum natural property
and this is saying that if you can learn
c
then this learning algorithm can be used
to distinguish the truth table
of of a function that can be computed by
the secret class
from from random functions okay
and i'll talk more about uh about it in
the next slide
and then the second step is that if if
you assume that
p space is hard then you can construct a
prg
that fools uniform quantum circuits
and again i'll define things more more
precisely in
in the next few slides and and and to
show the
this result we use
we build up on on different results from
the classical literature
but we need to to to quantize them
uh and and for some of these resulting
specifically for a jkw
this is highly non-trivial
and finally when you have these two
steps so when you have this
natural properties and you have these
prg's we can use a win-win argument
and we can show that if p space is easy
then we can find simple circular bounds
and if b space is hard then you can use
our assumption like we can use step two
and build our prg that can fool this
quantum natural property coming from our
quantum learning
algorithm okay so this is the
the big picture and i'll try to in the
rest of this talk try to explain
a bit uh what we're doing in each step
so first let me talk about uh natural
properties
so uh classical natural properties they
introduced by
by rnr in 97 and with the hope of
at least finding a barrier to the of how
to prove key versus anything
and what they show is that uh or
whatever they define that a proper
property gamma is called d natural
uh against uh some circuit class c if if
it has three properties
so first is constructivity so that is
that
uh if you're given the exponential size
truth table
of some function deciding
if it is uh if it has this property or
not if it belongs to this uh
you can think of about a property as a
set of functions
so uh the constructivity asks if
given the truth table of the function
deciding if it has property or
if it belongs to this set is decidable
in this complex
class d we also ask
largeness and the point is a allergen is
saying that if you pick a random
function
it has this property with high
probability
and finally we have usefulness is that
the point is error
for large enough n all these functions
that can be computed uh
by the circuit class uh with uh
uh with size n doesn't
like all of these functions do not have
the property so in some sense
this natural property is separating
random functions
from uh functions that can be computed
by a circuit class for for
big enough input size
and they use this to show that okay if
you have hope to to prove
p z or p is different of np this proof
has to be non-relativizing so so there
is that this it can be not casted
as this type of uh of arguments
and our first contribution is defining
uh for the first time
what you call a quantum natural property
and it is uh
okay uh uh an extension of this um
of this classical ones where now for
constructivity
we want that given the truth table
of the function you run a quantum
polynomial time algorithm and the
polynomial here is uh
compared to the size of the sort the
the size of the truth table of the
function so it's exponential in the
input size
and we want that for large enough
n uh if you pick like
there exists uh then set gamma n so
let's say
a constant fraction of the functions on
n bits
it turns out that this algorithm output
one
or or for for every
for every input in this band set with
priority exponentially close to one
so again here's just saying that if you
pick okay morally saying that if you
pick a random function
or of size n it means that this quantum
algorithm should
output one with very high probability
and finally we also have usefulness
where we want that for
functions better in this circuited class
they get rejected by
this um by this content circuit okay at
least
except with a negative probability so
the
this quantitative properties they are
just the extension uh
of classical ones but then you have to
be more
more subtle because the completed sounds
might not be one so
this is where these issues appear like
or these technicalities appear
but uh but the intuition is the same
here
and our first result is showing that if
you have a learning algorithm
for the secret class c then we have uh
with the parameters that i said before
then you actually have a quantum natural
property against c
so in other words if you can learn c you
can distinguish
functions computed by c and random
functions
and the idea here is just like
using this learning algorithm you can
compute a hypothesis
to to to the function and then you can
just check if if your hypothesis is
correct so you can just pick
uh some inputs informal at random
and since you notice that uh remember
that it is uh
this natural property it has the truth
table of a function so you can just
compare the output of your of your
learning hours or the output of your
hypothesis
with the truth table that this learning
algorithm got
okay and we can show that these three
properties of uh
of quantum natural properties hold so by
definit by the definition for but the
parameters that we
choose uh we have that the runtime is
polynomial in the
size of truth table
and also by the parameters of
learning algorithm it turns out that
that
random random functions should not have
unitaries
uh of this size so so the learning
algorithm will not be able to to compute
the matrix or even like even the circuit
uh
instead of the matrix is the circuit
that computes uh this random function so
so largeness
also holds and finally we also have
usefulness by the definition by the
assumption of our learning hours and so
we have the assumption that our learning
algorithm learns well
functions that are in the circuit class
so the
hypothesis that is output by this
learning algorithm should uh
should do well on these uh test inputs
okay so yeah this is um
not very hard uh but if there is any
question please let me know
okay the second building block are
prgs and uh you might know from
cryptography these are uh
these are functions that allow us to
stretch some true
um true and small seeds to a larger
pseudorandom string that can fool some
some sort of adversaries
so let me let me describe it more
formally the prg that we consider here
and these are functions gn that receives
as input
some end to the alpha bit string
and the output some to the
end to the del uh to the lambda uh with
strings
and and here we uh you can think of
lambda
uh lambda is just a constant between
zero and uh
one over five and alpha is an arbitrary
um is an arbitrary number here
and an arbitrary integer
and uh the only okay we have two two
properties that we require from this
krg is that it can be it can be computed
in
time two to the end to the alpha
and it turns we also require that for
every uniform family of quantum circuits
cm
uh this uh the output of this quantum
circuit
on on truly random inputs
or on on the output of this quantum
circuit
when when it's given as an output of
this uh of this prg
should be roughly the same so the the
the the punches all of these
quantum circuits cannot distinguish
which is the case if it's the
if it was given a random input or a
pseudo-random one
okay this is a somewhat standard
definition of prg
but uh here what's important is are
these parameters that i was trying to
not get the technical but uh
and uh so using this prg
here's what we were able to show is that
uh for every circuit class
at least one of these two things is true
so
we can show that there exists a language
in bqe
that can not be computed by
boolean series of size and to the k
or we can show that uh
that giving a uh
a quantum natural property against this
circuit uh
of size uh like the civic class with
size n to the a then the size of
like the problems that can be solved in
deterministic exponential size
are not in uh distributed class with a
size parameter n to the a
over over eta
and uh so the idea of
of this result is by uh so is by
like we showed this by a win-win
argument so uh the first cases assume
that p
space is a bit you time to the end to
the to the gamma
then uh by the result we can show that
there exists some language in this space
that is included in bbq okay this is
directly from
oliveira santana
and the most important or the most
interesting part is showing that if
p space is not limited time two to the n
to the gamma
uh what we can show is that uh then we
can instantiate the pure
appear g that i that i described in the
last slide
and this prg uh since it's uh
secure against uniform quantum
computations
it will be to full uh like
we can find uh sorry since this prg
fulls every uniform quantum computation
we can
use this quantum natural property to
find uh some function
that is not in distributed class so
let me explain it with uh with um
with a picture so we have that uh
if you consider a set of all possible
functions we have
the uh the pre-image of one or
considering of this quantum natural
properties and we know that this set is
large by the largeness
of of the largest property of quantum
natural properties
and we have the the the zero per image
it might be small but we also have the
zero per image but in particular it
contains the circuit class
by by the usefulness of this quantum
natural property
and uh what we showed that free space uh
is not easy so if
if p space is not included in bq time uh
with those parameters then uh
then the point is this uh this
we can implement the prg that cannot be
distinguished for a random function
so in particular these uh the out but
for
for different values of x's this uh
prg should fall into should give us
a truth table that lies in the
uh in the preimage of one so in
particular
whenever you have some x that gives us a
function that lies in a preimage of one
by by by the definition of quantum
natural properties
it means that this function that lies
here cannot be cannot have a circuit of
small size
so just uh saying again what i explained
before so what to show that
with a prg and this quantum natural
property we can show that
e does not uh is not contained in the
circuit class
and i think i'm a bit running out of
time so
so so yeah the the point is as i said uh
we can see g of uh like fixing the input
x we can see g n of x as a truth table
of a function
and uh since we know that uh g is a prg
so
so any any algorithm also the natural
property b
should uh should behave the same if it's
given a
pseudo random uh true stable or a random
tooth table
and therefore there sees some input x uh
star such that uh this uh this function
gn x star is not in circuit class
because
because half of half of the this roughly
half
of of this pseudorandom truth tables
should fall in the preimage of one
and the the main question is how can you
find such a pre-image
and the point is we don't need to we
just need to define the right language
and the
the language that will be the the hard
one that cannot be solved by the circuit
class
is just by the pair x and y
where uh where we consider
uh gx uh of y it's like the eighth bit
of gx
and uh by by the conditions that we
added
to this um to the circuit class it means
that
since there is existence x star such
that this function is hard
then these languages also be hard so so
the
this lifting from the hardness of of
this function
uh gn x-star will be lifted to to the
to like the hardness of this language it
will be lifted to the
hardness of algae
and we have that lg can be solved in
exponential time because they would
appear
that the time we have a time bound on
the prg size
or sorry the prg runtime
and we have by definition that lg is not
in the circuit class because uh
because you have these hard functions uh
one of these
for one of these x star it is not
inserted class
so their only remaining part or
of this result is showing this
conditional prg so showing that if p
space is not containing dq time
two to the end to the gamma then such a
prg exists
and this is shown by uh by a series of
steps so the first one is uh using this
nice p space hard problems and then uh
considering uh like the concatenation or
the parallel repetition
of each of these of this function
multiple times
uh applying gold hash leving
trick and finally use this
function uh in the nissan vector
figure construction to to construct
prg's
and uh if you compose all these steps
what to show is
if there exists a distinguisher with
some advantage for this prg
then we can actually construct some
algorithm
that can compute this function gl with
uh with a probability at least a half
plus gamma
and then from a result by ad [ __ ] and
cleave we can show that if you can
compute the
gold height leveling of some function
you can also compute some function
with with some like with some
probability
with probability gamma cubed over two
and this is this was the hardest
technical part of our result is showing
that if you can compute some function
like the parallel repetition of the
function
or the direct sum of the function um
uh with with a very small probability so
we might
should imagine here gamma to be let's
say 2 to the
minus n over two then we can come up
with a circuit c that computes the
function at the original function
f or with reality one minus one over
upon so so
from here we're going from success uh
probability exponentially small
to uh almost one and from that
you can go using the niceness of this p
space hard problem
we can uh we we can have an algorithm
for uh quantum algorithm for b space but
here by by your assumption that p space
is not immediate time to
the end to the gamma uh this is a
contradiction so
such a such a prg so so such a
distinguisher
cannot exist and therefore the prg is
secure
and i'd like just to finish with some
open problems so
the the first one is can you design
learning algorithms and find
new circular bounds and some candidates
are hcc
and torres polynomials for example
in our result we show some efficient prg
against uniform
families of quantum circuits
and one one of the key points of showing
this prg is uh
showing hardness amplification and one
of the one i think
very interesting open question is trying
to find other applications of this
harness amplification the quantum
setting
and thank you for attention
okay so uh thank you alex very much
and uh so there were some questions
during your talk you still have
uh just one minute or a couple of
minutes for questions
is any
what's a taurus polynomial good question
yeah i'll just uh my i don't know if
igor is around
igor knows it
yeah so apparently okay this somehow is
something intermediate between uh acc
and um
nc one so so some something terminated
between these two these two
circuit classes
okay another question okay so this
doesn't seem to be the case so we will
stop now and continue in half an hour at
11
45 so thank you alex for your time